lors de la première utilisation c'est un
peu impressionnant quand on n'a pas
l'habitude mais c'est assez simple
d'utilisation de ce que j'ai vu c'est
plutôt bien utilisés je pensais plutôt
une bonne chose
moi je les ai utilisés mais seulement en
vacances pour se déplacer à ces
pratiques des usagers qui dans
l'ensemble respecte les règles et une
cohabitation qui se passe plutôt bien
après près d'un mois d'utilisation le
premier bilan du service de trottinettes
électriques est plutôt satisfaisant on
constate que le service justement
rencontre un franc succès
un lancement qui a vraiment été très
performant ce nous avait agréablement
surpris l'opérateur aussi qui fait son
son deuxième lancement mondial le plus
le plus efficace dans les dix premiers
jours dix mille personnes ont utilisé
les trottinettes électriques pour
environ 6000 trajet de bons chiffres
mais certains utilisateurs adoptent
parfois de mauvais comportements au
départ un certain nombre de mineurs qui
est utilisée si trottinette
hu a aussi parfois encore deux personnes
par trottinette mais ça a tendance à
s'améliorer assez assez largement depuis
que nous sommes passés 450 a mis l'engin
de dégradations ont également été
constatés pour régler cela des
ajustements vont être faits les polices
municipales de nos douze communes sont
évidemment averti donc il ya un volet
toujours pédagogie et de sensibilisation
et un volet de sanctions quand la
personne est en infraction au code de la
route
elles sont toutes équipées d'une puce
gps et la personne aujourd'hui qui
réserve sa trottinette et qui ne replace
pas la trottinette sur une station
clairement défini se verra attribuer des
pénalités financières puis nous aurons
dans les prochaines semaines également
un système qui permettra via
l'application de relier la carte
d'identité et donc d'avoir l'âge de la
personne qui veut réserver débloquer sa
trottinette et si c'est un mineur il ne
pourra plus le faire
l'agglomération continue donc ses
campagnes de prévention vise à ces
réseaux sociaux mais reste sereine ans
bientôt un mois près de 2000 pas ses
abonnements ont été achetés le service
de trottinettes électriques a pour le
moment
de beaux jours devant lui à saint
quentin en yvelines